a major part of the first Last of Us
game follows Joel Ellie Henry and Sam as
they explore the sewer tunnels that run
beneath Pittsburgh in the show the
location has been changed to Kansas City
and the tunnels are referred to as
maintenance tunnels by Henry the chapter
in the game takes a long time as the
four characters must fight against a
battalion of infected while they learn
about the small community that once
lived underground fans of the game are
rewarded with a great scene in the show
in which the characters discover a
familiarly colorful room with books toys
and drawings everywhere taped to the
wall is a drawing of two men labeled
Danny and ish that reads our protectors
through recovering artifacts and notes
in the game you learn that ish was a sea
captain who built a safe house in the
Pittsburgh sewers over the years more
and more people joined him including
Dany who helped acquire guns and gear to
fend off the infected or healthy
trespassers